[Music]
I got it
all right
yeah yeah
a guy could get used to this
it's Friday and you know what that means
for one hour I'll meet your every single
need
yeah those two but first let's welcome
tonight's guests he sells his fans
razors in case they prefer suicide come
eat in David Anthony
can we go back to Angela real quick
doesn't he look like a member of Kiss
without the makeup
to whiz they put her on Philly
cheesesteaks Fox Business anchor
Lawrence Seminary
his published opinions terrify the
minions Fox News get flipping or Charlie
finally she's like Barbie small blonde
and has fake hair upstairs contributor
all right I know now before we get to
some news stories and we have plenty of
them let's do this
yeah Greg's leftovers
yeah it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading them
so if they suck we'll tie Joe Mackey to
a table and then let a group of monkeys
rip off his face
okay
might be an improvement
yeah I know he is homely
here we go
Brian kill me took on Tyrus in a
wrestling bout this week
in a match called the Unstoppable Force
versus the unwatchable object
there's a contrast of tyrus's power
against the skills kill me to learn
playing soccer namely boring people to
death
meanwhile an Austrian grocery store was
evacuated after a spider whose bites
caused four hour erections was found in
the banana section
[Laughter]
that's the setup I didn't even get to
the punch line
and a related story guess who just
announced he's moving to Austria
[Applause]
the heat index got as high as 158
degrees in fact it was so hot they had
to cancel the annual wet burka contest
Charlie finds that funny
uh people even groaned here
according to a new study long-term use
of popular acid reflux drugs has been
linked to a higher risk of dementia as
well as a loss of smell
[Laughter]
you just want to show that picture a new
study shows that nearly half of men with
thinning hair will avoid socializing but
then again some men will just cover it
up
[Applause]
a doctor told PBS NewsHour this week
that Americans should start wearing
masks again even inside their own homes
oh thank God said the husband of this
woman
she's really helped this show
nearly 10 000 people have offered to
change their name to Subway for the
chance to get free subs for life and I
think you know five of them
that would be confusing if all their
names were Subway
Goldberg
a trans woman aren't they all
is suing her ex-boyfriend to return her
surgically removed testicles
saying that he keeps them in the fridge
this could be bad I remember telling my
old roommate hey if you don't put your
name on it I'm gonna eat it
it keeps its testicles in a jar why not
why don't you just identify as married
[Laughter]
during the World Cup Megan rapino Mr
final shot as a member of the women's
national team
I know but she did pull off the
trickiest goal of all making soccer even
less popular
Mike Pence has qualified for the first
Republican debate which is great news
for the dozens of Engineers mechanics
and electricians who built Mike bence
during a speech this week Donald Trump
mock Chris Christie's weight it was the
first time the media didn't try to fact
check him
foreign
says the average American needs 200
cookies a year so finally Chris Christie
is ahead in a poll
[Laughter]
I like cookies while fishing in the
Florida Keys Tampa Bay or Jane Castor
found 70 pounds of cocaine usually to
find 70 pounds of coke you have to visit
the White House
and finally Cinnabon Cinnabon Cinnabon
bun Simon LeBron
Cinnabon Simon Labon
that's a great name for a kid anyway La
Cinnabon Workers are striking for the
right to display a pride flag in their
franchise franchise hungry Cinnabon
customers say they may cross the picket
line as long as there aren't any stairs
[Applause]
yeah smattering
that I can hear the monkeys feeding off
of Joe Mackey's face right now all right
to the news she had a meltdown in
economy class and watched the media to
get off her ass I speak of Tiffany Gomez
a 38 year old marketing executive from
this Infamous incident on board an
American Airlines flight last month when
she complained a fellow passenger wasn't
real something I've told human resources
about Judge Jeanine since day one
grow it
what I'm telling you I'm getting the
off and there's a reason why I'm
getting the
can either Believe it or they cannot
believe it I have two but I am telling
you right now
back there is not real
and you can see anything
or not I'm not going to
oh
some back there is bothering her
the Outburst delayed the flight three
hours causing American Airlines to issue
a statement that said no passenger has
the right to cause a pointless
three-hour delay because that's their
job
at any rate
this freak out will definitely go down
in the annals of airplane freakouts but
she's telling the Daily Mail that no one
should judge her and her life has been
blown up and everything has changed
since the video went very viral now Tiff
says no one knows anyone else's story
and no one knows what it's like there's
certainly a lot of passengers who've
been in her shoes according to the FAA
there have been more than 1100 unruly
passenger reports so far just this year
not counting of course the 100 or so
from the lonely guy in 14c who keeps
asking don't you know who I am
anyway we finally got our hands on the
unedited version of Tiffany's outburst
and who she was referring to when she
said that
what's not real I didn't give two
but I am telling
stuff back there is not real
fast true
David uh you have a kind of a low-key
presence but you have a very short fuse
I've seen you get very angry and just
beat up children
um have you ever been unruly on a flight
no I've never been unruly on a on a
flight I try to stay calm yeah
um you know but I I now appreciate the
older you get you appreciate freakouts
more I think why you just get them you
know what I mean yeah like when you're
young it's like what is this crazy
person
then you're middle aged you're like yeah
I get it yeah
I wouldn't mind screaming at a crowd of
people now and then yeah
yeah we're always going to
goodness I have
a people are always looking at me trying
to wait for me to snap oh yeah and
that's coming yeah
you could see it right this is not gonna
be good no it's not it's I know that I'm
just I'm walking towards the edge right
she's gonna be making fun of you that
one
I hope she does Lauren what do you think
cost or meltdown why does he just come
out and say that's what I think yeah he
said her life is over nobody gets it
well help us get it if there is a mental
health issue we'd probably be
sympathetic right and instead
everybody's attacking her because she
lives in a near 2 million dollar home
and is wearing a 1900 bag who cares yeah
she has an issue tell us what it is
because it doesn't look like she's gonna
I think don't get jobs in the future you
know with this in your background this
is what's BS about it it's like so what
if you have a viral moment let her get
on with her life right why should we
care whether she gets another job or not
that's what bugs me is that we're all
acting like it'll never happen to us but
it will
especially you Charlie oh I I it's I've
Come Close yeah um I'm not much into uh
viral videos but I have to say from the
moment this thing hit I have watched uh
every second of it and actually the the
um and I don't know what she's
complaining about she first of all she's
a marketing exec you would think that if
you're a marketing exec then you know a
viral video is great makes something out
of it and stop complaining about it and
a lot of people love her because she
spoke for him
um I will warn you against watching the
whole long video the one that's in
context is way more boring yeah this one
she was speaking truth in the short
version you know what you just brought
up an interesting point If This Were
Made in Hollywood this would be three
hours long
and there'd be all this build up
background romantic interest pointless
conversations with her and somebody in
front of her and then behind her the um
gay but all-knowing flight attendant
talking to his uh married his husband
about their two twin babies on the phone
there'll be the plot the subplot where
the plane could be going under at any
time but it's not even that interesting
because you know it's just and then you
get to that
and it's five minutes yeah so so she's a
hero to many and a lot of people thought
she's hot too that which helps but the
problem for her is apparently once the
more information comes out it turns out
she was mad at a relative she was
traveling with who apparently stole her
earbuds yes for her phone and so that is
kind of a warning flag that maybe she's
maybe you don't want to hang out with
her she bought it see I think I I could
see this you know that you need like a
little flow chart for a children's book
and it's like the first one is Ambien
and then you get the big plus size
Chardonnay
uh divided by earbuds that fell into the
crease of your chair
equals I hate my relatives uh how not to
book yeah that's exactly what happened
it's like all it takes is a mix of two
things and your life is over Kat do you
have any insight into this story the
story that you know what other networks
are too scared to cover yeah no I
honestly think that it's not really a
warning sign so much as an opportunity
that if her family is fighting like this
in public imagine what they're doing at
home so we should get some cameras in
there
I I completely agree that as someone
who's Mark and marketing she's totally
wasting this opportunities there should
be merch she could do a show where she
interviews other people whose lives have
maybe you know they had a viral meltdown
and how to use it to transfer called
meltdown glow up nice
nice she could probably start a cult
even if she said like oh no I saw this
thing you guys the aliens are here
thousands of people would believe her I
would I thought that she for a moment
there I thought she had seen something
because it's like look it's there I mean
she was like that was the best acting
again Hollywood couldn't do that yeah I
mean if you're gonna come out and say
something about it like she did you have
to do better than don't judge me don't
judge you know say no it's real you guys
listen next you know boom cult I would
also just add you know
if she's worried about not getting a job
in marketing I Western razor Western
razor we would be happy to have her come
on board
you know be a part of the team yeah you
have a big team don't you it's a huge
team you know the team includes all of
America
by the way America's largest
American-made Razor Company yeah he owns
a razor company and it's made in America
and you refer to your your staffers as
male and female unlike Harry's Racers
which uh birthing and non-birthing
people yeah so I'm helping you we do
because we only have it's it's men yeah
that's at my staff yeah it's you it's me
and my friend
I don't care hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else